Okay that was a simple case. Okay, and now have to consider the,
the case in which the vectors do have elements, and
we're going to also break this down into two more cases, depending on whether or
not the first elements of x and y are identical. Okay? So
first case is, yes they are identical. So in this case,
determining whether X and Y are permutation, boils down to whether or
not the tails of X and the tail of Y are permutations of each other.
And the tail of a vector is everything except the first element. So we could say
that, for this case, in order for the output to be a permutation of the input,
the syntax on the. That you see on the slide holds. In particular that says,
if the length of X is greater than 0, that's our special case.
And our second special case was that the value in the first position of
X is equal to the value of the first position in Y. And the third condition is
if the permutation if, if the tail of X is a permutation of the tail of Y
than we can conclude that in fact X and Y are permutations of each other.
So what were doing now we, we handled the case where they were empty vectors and
said they were permutations and in this case if these three conditions hold,
they are permutations, okay? The other thing to note, is that, what we've
defined here. Is a recursive definition. Now I warned you before about recursive
definitions, often leading to cases where the definition is not meaningful.
Now here I'm going to give you a specific situation in which you
are allowed to do that. And we're allowed to do that because it essentially is,
is an inductive argument. Okay? The permutations that we're using
in our definition, are permutations on the tails of the input and output,
okay? And the tails are everything but the first element and so they're shorter.
And we also already have handled the case where we got down to 0 length.
So we handled 0 length, and we handled everything in terms of its tail.
We have a well founded induction here. And so
in fact, our definition of permutation is in fact meaningful.
We couldn't say that, X is a permutation of Y if X is a permutation of Y.
Okay? That wouldn't be a meaningful induction. But here because we're
shrinking it at every step, it is in fact a meaningful induction.